[Music]
says we are one in Spanish and Smalley
and English I want my son to know that
everyone is welcome and that we all
share a common humanity and I want him
to not be trust distrustful of our
neighbors
[Music]
I think that this is a great way to both
remind people who are really hurting and
are going to be targeted and then the
coming weeks and months that they're
loved and also mobilize people who might
otherwise not know what to do with that
energy and my turn to cynicism
[Music]
unfortunately it's not easy to be an
immigrant and Refugee and Muslim and
who's also from Somalia and because of
that you have seen a lot of people who
are sending us a lot of hate messages
that's why we really want to focus on
the love what we have in common as a
country as a community as in Minnesota
[Music]
my hope is that those people will then
maybe join the next protest maybe they
will work on the next electoral campaign
this is not a moment to worry more about
people's feelings that about people's
lives
you
[Music]